it depends on what she believes in or there
was no fear the truth and the
last time when we talked to her at the
festival the tradition says for the pub
I feel in it thanks to the
heroes
I want to be like that I don’t want any but
also fate I
want to be with my people with my
fear, the price that she
has to pay can only be
justified higher more achievement by
victories she lived in the name of victory
she will perish during the victory of our Russian
victory our from the
Orthodoxy of our country even this
forgive
what should be the response of Russia on the one
hand
uncompromising
diversification demilitarization of ukraine
uncompromising actions unity
inside
remained in particular, of course,
I’m only even elements relatively on the
basis of public convictions here,
I
can’t judge that it was
an act of intimidation at accounts, I think that this is a
barbaric crime for which there is
no forgiveness and those who
organized it, and now, as I understand it, the FSB
already established the facts that are now
being investigated  I hope the investigation will be
completed quickly and, as a result of this
investigation, of course, the organizer of the
customers and performers cannot have
any mercy,
but this is a blow to every ordinary
person who walks the streets today
because they show by this that they
can deliver anyone, but I want to
tell you that they  made a very big
mistake because we will only become even stronger
because we must protect
each other we must defend the honor of
our sisters
such an event in the capital
will actually
help to convey to our authorities that we should
stop playing a special operation to
start a full-fledged serious war
from the first  very pukhova on mobilization, well,
as he called, and Alek, in fact, cabbage soup and
many others,
this applies to everyone, this is nowhere overpayments at
our very doorstep